hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 36 hört zu und spricht nach
ich wohne in einem haus ich wohne in
einem haus ich wohne in einem reihenhaus
ich wohne in einem reihenhaus
ich wohne in einem mehrfamilienhaus ich
wohne in einem mehrfamilienhaus ich
wohne in einem hochhaus ich wohne in
einem hochhaus ich wohne im erdgeschoss
ich wohne im erdgeschoss ich wohne im
ersten stock ich wohne im ersten stock
meine wohnung ist im zweiten stock meine
wohnung ist im zweiten stock die art
praxis ist im dritten stock die
arztpraxis ist im dritten stock mein
büro ist im vierten stock mein büro ist
im vierten stock wohnst du im fünften
stock wohnst du im fünften stock mein
haus hat drei stockwerke mein haus hat
drei stockwerke meine wohnung hat einen
balkon
[Musik]
meine wohnung hat einen balkon
meine wohnung hat zwei badezimmer meine
wohnung hat zwei badezimmer zu meiner
wohnung gehört ein garagenplatz zu
meiner wohnung gehört einen garagenplatz
ich wohne
ich wohne alleine
ich wohne mit meinem freund zusammen
ich wohne mit meiner familie zusammen
ich wohne in einer wohngemeinschaft
meine nachbarn sind laut meine nachbarn
sind laut meine nachbarn machen oft lärm
[Musik]
meine nachbarn machen oft lernen
meine nachbarn sind nett meine nachbarn
sind nett meine nachbarn sind
hilfsbereit
meine nachbarn sind hilfsbereit
in der küche gibt es eine waschmaschine
in der küche gibt es einen kühlschrank
in der küche
das einen hielt in der küche gibt es
eine nähert mein auto steht in der
garage
mein auto steht in der garage
mein auto steht auf dem parkplatz ein
auto
steht auf dem parkplatz mein auto steht
vor dem haus mein auto steht vor dem
haus gewohnt
immer hängt ein fernseher an der wand im
wohnzimmer hängt ein fernseher an der
wand im wohn
steht ein esstisch im wohnzimmer steht
ein esstisch im wohnzimmer gibt es ein
sofa im wohnzimmer
gibt es ein sofa im badezimmer gibt es
eine dusche im badezimmer gibt es eine
dusche im badezimmer gibt es eine
badewanne im badezimmer gibt es eine
badewanne im badezimmer hängt ein
spiegel im bad
zimmer hängt ein spiegel der hausherr
wechselt die lampen aus der haus
hat wechselt die lampen aus der haus
putzt das treppenhaus der haus abfahrt
putzt das treppenhaus der hausherr
hat wischt vor dem eingang der haus
abwischt vor dem eingang
kuster immobilien gerührt sie guten tag
herr kostet er spricht sie die sehne ich
habe ihre anzeige auf der seite mein
zuhause punkt ch gefunden
mich interessiert die mietwohnung in
wollishofen grüezi herr zehner um
welches objekt handelte sich genau
wir haben mehrere häuser und wohnungen
zu vermieten in wollishofen also die
viereinhalb zimmer wohnung an der
bruchstraße 19 in wollishofen
sie ist im erdgeschoss und hat einen
kleinen garten einen moment ich schaue
in unserer datenbank nach ja die wohnung
ist noch frei unser limit ist 2500
franken
ich habe gelesen dass die miete 2300
franken ist es kommen aber noch die
nebenkosten dazu was sind die
nebenkosten die wohnung hat eine
bodenheizung es kommen also noch die
kosten für die heizung das wasser und
den strom dazu
ich hoch sind die ungefähr im
durchschnitt circa 250 franken im monat
dann kommt ja auch noch der karossen
platz für das auto dazu
das wären dann pro monat zwei 1650
franken
das ist über unsere willi mit also sie
müssen den garagenplatz nicht nehmen vor
dem haus gibt es genug parkplätze die
kosten nichts
wenn sie wollen können sie ihr auto dort
passieren
das werde ich mir überlegen ich habe
noch eine frage
wir haben einen hund ist das ein problem
in diesem wohnhaus sind haustiere
zugelassen aber natürlich keine pferde
unser hund ist ein bieter ist nicht groß
die schule entfernt die primarschule ist
ca 300 meter entfernt die kinder müssen
über keine straße laufen
das ist super ich halte nämlich 100
prozent und meine frau teilzeit wir
wollen dass die kinder alleine zur
schule gehen können
das verstehe ich natürlich sie müssen
keine angst haben das haus liegt nicht
an der straße und der weg zur schule ist
nur für fußgänger die wohnung
interessiert mich sehe dann kann ich die
wohnung besichtigen
also morgen um 15 uhr hettich zeit kann
kann ich leider nicht
ich arbeite bis 17 uhr außerdem würde
ich gern meine familie dabei haben geht
es ihnen am abend ja übermorgen am
mittwochabend um 18.30 super ja das geht
vielen dank also sie haben ja die
adresse wir treffen uns beim hauseingang
am mittwochabend bringen sie bitte den
betreibungsauzug und ihren ausweis mit
wenn ihnen die wohnung gefällt können
wir gleich die anmeldung gemeinsam
ausfüllen
das werde ich machen bis dann herr
kuster und vielen dank ich danke ihnen
herr sie die szene auf wiederhören
auf wiederhören
[Musik]